this is angela merkel's last visit to
washington dc to the white house
as german chancellor nordstrom 2 set to
be
one of the topics that they will be
talking about in those meetings between
herself and u.s president joe biden it's
the
major stumbling block between relations
um
between washington and berlin right now
angela merkel saying that the
uh the much needed here in germany gas
pipeline
is part of ongoing cooperation with
russia
cooperation that she wants to see
continue
no one wants to be unilaterally
dependent on russia
but we received russian guests not only
in the ddr where i lived
but also in west germany during the cold
war
and i don't see why the times today
should be so much worse
that we can no longer say russia remains
a partner
the united states though see this
project very differently
president trump during his time in the
white house sanctioned it
well into submission for a little while
it was delayed by a year and a half and
cost
untold amounts of millions of dollars in
those delays
joe biden has lifted those sanctions
however
that doesn't mean that he likes the
project at all
i have been opposed to nordstrom 2 from
the beginning
but it only has it's almost completed
by the time i took office and to go
ahead and
close sanctions now that i think is
counterproductive in terms of our
european relations
ultimately um it's uh in contradiction
to
the eu's own energy security goals i'm
sure i'll
have an opportunity to reiterate that
including
uh the law in the united states which uh
requires us to sanction
companies participating in the efforts
to uh complete the pipeline
whether the u.s likes it or not the
north stream 2 pipeline is around 98
complete according to its project
director they're expecting the
construction phase to be finished in
august after that they say around three
months for certification
and safety checks to be carried out then
gas will start flowing through the
pipeline from russia
directly into germany it is one of those
major stumbling blocks between in the
relations as i say
angela merkel earlier this week saying
she's not expecting any major
breakthroughs when it comes to the
nordstrom 2
impasse between washington and berlin
there's also a chance that they'll be
discussing another area that there is an
impasse as well and that's on china
angela merkel has been a big advocate of
closer ties with beijing
the us seeing things going a very
different way
we're looking to see what the german
chancellor and the u.s president discuss
and what the results of those
discussions are
when they meet in washington later on
thursday
you